[Applause]
we're going to shift now to a more
celebratory note after hearing both the
the possible benefits but also some of
the risks and concerns shift to a
celebration through the awarding of two
professorships as part of the K&L gates
endowment in ethics and computational
technologies chaired professorships are
some of the highest honors that can be
awarded upon a faculty member and they
recognize their excellence in education
in research in outreach and in all the
things that are key to faculty members
role within the broader University and I
think in particular in this case I
wanted to read a quote from our very own
herb Simon who made several appearances
in the keynote which is he said in 2000
we are not observers of the future we
are actors who whether we wish to or not
by our actions and our very existence
will determine the future shape
technology must be evaluated by its
ability to help us or hinder us in
pursuing our goals not by the flashing
lights that it enables us to produce and
I think one of the things that really
binds together both of the recipients of
professorships that were going to be
awarding tonight is that they both very
much have looked at how we can use
technology not just for the flashing
lights that it produces not just for the
pretty ROC curves that we can plot in
our paper that we give at a conference
but how it can actually help humans
advance and their own goals and
interests
so I'm now delighted to welcome dr.
Laurie weingartz who is the interim
provost of Carnegie Mellon and the
Richard m and Margaret as sired
professor of organizational behavior and
therapy in The Temper School of Business
Laurie is a nationally and
internationally recognized scholar on
group processes conflict management and
negotiation she's been a member of the
CMU faculty since 1989 and previously
served as the associate associate dean
for education at The Temper School as
interim provost at Carnegie Mellon she's
responsible for leading CMU's schools
colleges institutes and campuses and as
instrumental in the institutional and
academic planning and implementation
[Applause]
well thank you David for the
introduction you just turned me into a
therapist which sometimes I feel like is
a daily part of my job okay so I want to
thank also Eric for wonderful comments
we had today very insightful and as a
professor of organizational behavior in
theory I think a lot about these issues
in terms of how we interact with
technology in the workforce and what
impact that will have so I do want to
ask everyone to stick around for a few
minutes so we have two amazing faculty
that we're going to recognize but before
we do that I'd like to acknowledge the
pivotal role that K&L Gates has played
in putting this conference together and
of course partnering with Carnegie
Mellon so for that I'd like to invite
Jim Segre Dahl global managing partner
of K&L gates to the stage to join me to
receive a token of our appreciation and
share a few thoughts and while I'm not
going to hand over the token right now
what you see over here is a very a mini
chair so that was produced by our de FEV
lab 3d printing as a replica of our
larger professorship chairs so with that
I'll turn it over
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much and I
humbly and with much appreciation on
behalf of all of my colleagues that came
out Gates thank you for the gift and for
the token we're just thrilled and
excited to be part of this you know an
initiative like this really depends on
outstanding institutions outstanding
institutional support but ultimately it
comes down to outstanding people
outstanding people with a vision
outstanding people with the energy the
drive the intellectual curiosity to move
important things forward and I think
that's characteristic of of the
professorships that have being awarded
here as part of the kano Gates endowment
and we couldn't be prouder to be a part
of that and to be supporting that we'll
hear from them I want to congratulate
them personally and all the kano Gates
fellows and thank again CMU for being a
great partner to us and for its
incredible role in driving forward these
important issues so thank you again
okay now it's time to celebrate two
faculty members who had the distinction
of becoming the first K&L gates
professor professors of ethics and
computational technologies here at
Carnegie Mellon so to introduce the
first chair recipient will be Dean Dan
Martin who's Dean of the College of Fine
Arts dan joined Carnegie Mellon faculty
in 1992 to direct the Master of Arts
management program and later served as
director of the Institute of the
management of creative enterprises over
the substant subsequent 20 odd years or
so he found a number of innovative
programs here at Carnegie Mellon
including the center for arts management
and technology and the master of
entertainment industry management prior
to his higher education career dan spent
several years working in arts management
in New York Philadelphia and Norfolk
Virginia Akron Ohio and Kalamazoo
Michigan so we're certainly privileged
to have Dean Dean Dan as part of our
Carnegie Mellon family so please welcome
Dean dan Martin
[Applause]
thank you again Laurie and on behalf of
the college of fine arts I extend our
welcome to all of you and Tamale I offer
our heartfelt congratulations I'm
honored to formally and officially
present you to the campus community as
the first K&L Gates Career Development
professor of ethics and computational
technologies as you may have know as you
may know from reading Molly's biography
she has an esteemed reputation as a
multi-faceted professor professional
I'll get the words out I'll slow down on
my promise a designer author professor
speaker and architectural historian her
research focuses on the impact of
artificial intelligence in the design
and architectural domains and she's put
that knowledge to practice in her work
within both the School of Design and the
School of Architecture in the College of
Fine Arts Carnegie Mellon in her book
architectural intelligence how designers
and architects created the digital
landscape molly approaches architecture
in a different light focusing on design
processes and tools computer programs
interfaces and digital environments the
book highlights for architects whose
work in the 60s and 70s significantly
influenced digital design in the
industry
over the last four decades these
projects from a half century ago led to
so many of our contemporary interactive
practices from information architecture
to interaction design and from machine
learning to smart cities Molly's
credentials are impressive she holds a
master's degree in environmental design
from the Yale School of Architecture and
a doctorate in architecture from
Princeton she's in very high demand as a
keynote speaker both nationally
internationally she's been called a web
pioneer and profession and her
professional experience includes
engagements at both groundbreaking
design studios and fortune 500 companies
prior to joining Carnegie Mellon in 2015
Molly taught at the universe
wisconsin-madison the Art Center College
of Design in Pasadena and in Italy's
interaction design Institute of RIA we
are fortunate to have Molly with us and
we are so very grateful to K&L gates for
its recognition of Molly's work please
join me in welcoming to the podium
Molly Wright Steenson the new K&L gates
development professor of ethics and
computational technology thank you so
let me start by saying that I am so
pleased and honored to be the first
recipient of the K&L gates associate
professorship in ethics and
computational technologies and I want to
thank KL gates for the generous
contribution that has made this award
possible so as I'm standing here you
might be wondering why is a design
professor standing up here and what do
design in architecture and for that
matter history have to do with ethics
and computation architecture and design
meet us where we live architects and
designers create the world that we live
in and pioneers in computation
artificial intelligence and cybernetics
have long reached out to architecture
and design to help them talk about the
implications of their technologies and
their innovations for instance computing
pioneer Douglas Engelbart proposed the
Augmented human intellect system in 1962
in his proposal angle Bart used an
architect to show his vision of
computing at scale I think that
Engelbart understood something vital
about the power of computers and
architecture both that they are about
building worlds and today more than ever
computation is about building worlds and
we expect more from these worlds and
design is vital for this task designers
don't only make attractive products and
services designers frame problems they
frame problems so that we can solve them
and ask questions designers create
elegant products in
faces design plays an important role in
the kinds of open world challenges that
we were just hearing about and designers
contribute to creating systems that are
safe and fair I'm looking forward to
using the K&L gates associate
professorship in ethics and
computational technologies to support
questions about the role of design and
ethics in computation and I'm eager to
forge new pathways into the
intersections of AI and design and
architecture as Dean Martin noted my
work for the last decade has been about
forging that history I'm now looking
forward to forging its future I look
forward to bringing this work to new
audiences so they might better
understand the ramifications of
technology and better understand the
ethics and computation ethics of
computation in our everyday lives I have
many people that I'd like to thank first
of course I'd like to thank interim
provost Laurie weingartz for this chair
I'd like to express my sincere gratitude
to terry irwin the head of the school of
design who unfortunately couldn't be
here today
I first met Terry almost 20 years ago
when I worked with her at her company
Mehta design and it was an introduction
to a sophisticated way of design and
design thinking that I have been chasing
ever since I'd like to thank my
colleagues in the School of Design who
broadened and deepened my horizons I'm
grateful for their inspiration and I'd
also like to thank Steve Lee and my
colleagues in the School of Architecture
I owe much to the students who I work
with from undergraduates to masters to
the doctorate doctoral students I advise
one of whom just handed in her
dissertation today and it's here and who
I will see defend in the weeks to come
thank you for what you teach me I'd like
to thank Dean Dan Martin for his
recognition in his support and for
seeing across the horizons of the
College of Fine Arts too many
possibilities of what the arts can do at
a university such as this one and out
into the world beyond I'm thrilled for
the opportunity to build bridges across
campus and I wish to express my
gratitude with some of the people who
helped me to do that who include Golan
Levin Jody for lazy and John Zimmerman I
want to extend a very special thank you
to David Danks
for being a kindred spirit and fellow
traveler in pursuit of these important
questions and a very special thank you
to the dear friends and collaborators
here it seemed you who fuel so many
brilliant ideas and so much creative
energy you make it so exciting to be
here finally my husband Simon King
deserves all my love and gratitude he's
been a tremendous support in helping me
see this work out into the world and not
to mention seeing me through surgery on
a broken hand Thank You Simon King I
love you and finally thank you again to
Kol Gates for this chair and next we
have Dean Andrew Moore to introduce the
second K&L gates professor Andrew Moore
joined our faculty in 1993 and famously
took a leave of absence that's what he's
known for leaving Carnegie Mellon in
2006 to open Google's Pittsburgh office
with Andrew at its helm Google
Pittsburgh grew from 2 to 275 employees
and now anchors 14141 Bakery square
development just a few miles from campus
he returned to CMU in 2014 to serve as
dean of the school of computer science
and were certainly the better for it now
if he please welcome to the stage Dean
Andrew Moore
[Applause]
I'm so excited to see everyone here
today thank you very much for coming I
want to congratulate Molly I think we're
all super excited that you've been
recognized in this way and thank you
very much for being such a person who
reaches across campus I also want to
thank Eric Horvitz for coming here
taking part and that discussion with
David was great I was like in the back
sort of cheering alone that was
fantastic
and Carol gates thank you very much as
you see we act honey melon right now are
in a period where by chance or by
decades of planning we have faculty who
are figuring out what happens next for
the technological society we're going to
live in and retaining and recognizing
those faculty is critically important
and these kinds of professorships
exactly what we need right now so your
your the creation of these
professorships is disproportionately
important I think for helping an
institution which itself is helping the
world so that's all good now I have to
talk about Eleanor Bosch the recipient
of the first Carol Gates professorship
and what I basically have to say is this
is clearly an awful mistake ela has been
the bane of my life for years
I had to share an office next well not
share an office I was in an office next
to ela for about eight years of my
career and here's a typical thing the
way life would be I'm sitting with one
of my grad students really worried it's
like we don't get the same the ratio of
the second and third eigenvalue below 1
minus lambda you know we're completely
screwed and then either would bounce
past the open door on a artificially
intelligent pogo stick
shrieking and then two weeks later we'd
be like God in these asteroids if they
if we don't get there correct detection
they're gonna hit the earth at some
point soon and Eli would be rushing past
with a bunch of kids who are chasing
some escaped mobile robot so this is
exactly the way Eli is not actually a
pain in the butt but someone who has
brought real joy and passion and focus
and motivation to the study of advanced
technology throughout his career which
began at NASA involved some seminal work
on scheduling and optimization which
turned into a very successful startup
company carrying on with the work that
he's done on educational robotics and
really making it so that's folks outside
the normal walk of life of people at
Carnegie Mellon get to see the absolute
joy of combining the physical world with
algorithms and then going on to things
like the invention of the GigaPan
this amazing notion of a virtual
ultra-high resolution camera which has
shown us a whole different view of the
world and insight that you see the
things which make kind of email and in
general but ela is the perfect
representative of this so perfect it's
wonderful from an artistic and design
point of view inside it it is really
complicated
to actually make it so that you can
stitch together so many images in a way
that looks beautiful
and so I bet that actually during that
period of time
ela was actually having to worry about
the second and third eigen values of
some matrices just like he ought to so
that's good and then sort of moving on
from that
ela has in the past decade I think being
a leader in how computer science should
be practiced by people who care about
the future of the world and ela myself
Erik many other people David many other
people in this audience
we're often on panels and discussions of
technology impact and so often I hear
people so leaning back and saying yeah
someone should do this or it should be
done this way or governments should do
such and such and while we're sitting on
our comfy chairs talking ela and the
create lab are actually building stuff
for complaining about air quality he's
building stuff technologically to help
give real accountability to folks who
pollute 'end
help individuals understand when they're
in danger when it comes to these big
questions such as deforestation instead
of just saying it's a bad thing he has
successfully harnessed the massive
infrastructure used for world map
building to make folks accountable for
this and all the time as he's guiding
his students and people going through
the create lab he's peeling off if you
like dozens every year of students and
co-workers who go out and do the same
sort of thing this is my favorite kind
of ethical computer scientist the kind
who actually does something about it and
it with that I strongly congratulate
Allah for his award
[Applause]
well that was one hell of an
introduction Thank You Angie what I
wanted to is talk a little bit well let
me back up I've I've been in Pittsburgh
for two decades actually I was here
three decades ago because my brother was
at Saint Francis Medical Center which
doesn't exist but the old-timers you
know it and that means I was here when
the O was the only place to eat anything
this is a long time ago I've seen a lot
of changes here and as Carnegie Mellon
and Pittsburgh have changed and I've
been just wondrously witnessing that
there is one thing that is very special
which is the Carnegie Mellon and
Pittsburgh are the only places for the
kind of work that I wish to do there is
nowhere else that this work could happen
and I want to just give you a few
minutes on explaining why that is by
talking about some of the stakeholders
and I really mean it this is not
pandering to CMU at Pittsburgh this is
what makes this place uh truly unique
first of all students I was blessed when
I got here in negotiating a deal where I
teach experimental classes
interdisciplinary classes classes that
push on the boundaries of what we
normally consider a class and in all
those classes the students at Carnegie
Mellon have blown me away because they
are not students that sit in the classes
and take the classes there are students
that sit there and then make the class
they take control and they create an
agenda that creates fantastic learning
between all of them and me and that
attitude is something I saw peak here
during the Second Gulf War and then a
whole lot of startup companies started
and the student attitude went away the
ethics went away
some people even left and went to places
like Google for a few years but they
came back and then what happened is just
in the last four years I've seen an
exponential increase in the degree of
social awareness our students have they
are demanding interdisciplinary
education they're demanding that their
classes connect them to real social
outcomes and give them a considered way
in which to change the world to bend the
arc of the future for the better so to
me those students are incredible that
way and my hats off to them for
inventing the space in which we can
invent new
like AI in humanity which thanks to Dean
Moore and the Dean of the College of
Humanities enabled Crosse college
learning across humanity students and
computer science students at the same
time but then there's the staff and this
is where things get a little bit unusual
I think usually you have your newest
rate of staff who help you with things
like financials fundraising and room
scheduling but we have a staff in the
robotics Institute that have had
luncheons where I've talked about the
research I do and then they've had
long-standing opportunities where they
come and talk to me about the research
that we do and connect us to groups with
which I can do that research community
empowerment with technology so the staff
our intellectual peers to us here and I
think that's very very rare to see
because they're often treated in the
wrong way at universities and of course
in that same staff category I have to
put the entire create lab because it's
fine to talk about me inventing all
these technologies but in fact in fact
what I mostly do is called fundraising
it is the create lab 30 people who
consider how they can have positive
impact on the world that then go out and
invent systems that we can all be proud
of
then there's faculty and this is where
things get interesting because when I
came to Carnegie Mellon it was I believe
quite clear that you succeed by having
disciplinary depth in a single
discipline and the sea change that I've
seen in the time that I've been here is
that in fact we as a faculty or willing
now to reward boundary work we're
willing to give tenure to somebody not
because they're the number one expert in
a single discipline but because they
have found a new way of tying together
across transdisciplinary boundaries
something that has important human
impact and that makes this a more human
University than it could ever have been
before
and that change in faculty attitude
means we take more risks and are more
willing to accept challenges that are
almost impossible to achieve now I want
to go to the city because the city is
equally special I had the benefit of
trying to fundraise in San Francisco for
a few years both during three
sabbaticals there and before I became
faculty here and I got to tell you
there's a lot of money there but because
there's so much money there the
datian community their supports the fads
they support the digital badges they
support the programs that are
quantitative that have metric outcomes
and that don't cause real change but
rather incremental change and here you
have a set of foundations who are
actually driven by the four PS that the
mayor announced this morning they're
driven by equity and by the idea of
inclusion of all the communities in
Pittsburgh so I have an entire
foundation class here as big as the one
in New York City for a smaller City that
actually cares deeply about social
welfare and this is the trick is willing
to invest obscene amounts of money in
technological innovation because they
understand how technological innovation
can cause social welfare you will not
find that in any other city in our Union
and then we can go to the
community-based organizations the
Allegheny County clean air now the group
against smog and pollution and dozens of
other institutions like Clean Water
Action work with us directly
hand to hand every day we the University
have won their trust and support because
we don't parachute in and then leave we
come into a community and we stay there
for decades at a time and that's
something I challenge you to find
elsewhere finally this is not the good
news but it's real there's the community
itself Pittsburgh the fabric of
Pittsburgh when you look at Pittsburgh
you can see great success in the last
decade or so massive success but what
you see in fact is one of the worst race
disparities in the United States one of
the larger inequities in wealth in the
United States one of the biggest
divisions in educational success and
deficiency in the United States we are a
crucible for change because we're so
horrible as a whole we're two cities
melted together with the barrier that is
like a Berlin wall and because
Pittsburgh is so bad at sharing its
wealth it is the perfect place for us to
innovate for social change using
technologies like AI because this is the
place where if we can succeed in
bridging the rampant gaps that we have
in race and wealth
and advantage then we have a formula a
structure that we owe it to ourselves to
apply all over the world so that makes
Pittsburgh and it makes Carnegie Mellon
absolutely unique places for the kind of
work that we do the kind of work that I
really can't imagine doing anywhere else
in summary there are too many people to
thank to thank them all but it is this
institution and this city that makes
this possible Kaenel gates you're part
of the city I have been befriending
individuals in your organization for
years now and I'm deeply indebted and
honored and humbled by you my whole
career has been about community
empowerment and the way I look at these
chairs and I gotta say I love mini-me I
love the mini chair so if there's a way
to swap them we can have that discussion
later the way I look at the chair though
in all seriousness is that it's an
obligation that this which has been my
only career and my whole career so far
is going to be my only career and I hope
that I can continue to do the best
that's possible with the resources of
Pittsburgh and the resources are
Carnegie Mellon so thank you to all
[Applause]
I think you can see from our two chair
recipients the breadth and the depth of
knowledge that we're bringing to bear
and setting the intersection between
artificial intelligence computational
technologies and ethics so with that
please join me in congratulating our two
chair recipients I'd like to thank you
all for joining us for our keynote and
for our chairs professorship ceremony
please join us for a reception in the
back of the room to honor our recipients
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]